uh WRAL news on Friday spoke to the
woman who ripped into a local barbecue
restaurant for serving her pink meat and
cook so her name is cook so maybe if
your name is cooked she feels like she
knows more than mostly can cook she
thinks and can cook
guys are you looking for the perfect
gift for Mom or another loved one the
Skylight digital photo frame is a sweet
and meaningful gift that will give you a
new way to stay in touch with those that
you love it's simple it's fun to use
even if you're not tech savvy Dan as a
special Mother's Day offer get 10 off up
to 30 off your frame when you go to
skylightframe.com DPT that's 10 off up
to 30 off your purchase of a skylight
frame just go to skylightframe.com DPT
that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash DPT
this show is sponsored by betterhelp if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule visit
betterhelp.com DPT to get 10 off your
first month that's betterhelp
help.com
hey gang if you're like me you want the
best for your dog I want the best for
little Ponyo maybe you feed them kibble
recommended by a vet or a fresh food
diet but did you know that these are
often low in protein high in carbs and
are the leading cause of weight Mobility
dental and skin conditions that's where
Maeve comes in maves raw food diet is
formulated to meet your dog's needs make
the switch to Raw today right now Maeve
is offering forty dollars off your first
order at meetmave.com DPT go to meet
Maeve that's
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v.com TPT I'm gonna do one
more time for you that's spelled
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars
off your first order that's meat
maev.com DPT hey townies welcome to
another episode of dumb people Town
population
Soder long time comment I'm so happy
you're here I finally get my honorary
key to dumb people Town hey man you're
in and it's a key that doesn't work it's
like one of those things it breaks off
you've done that yeah I did that
recently you broke down for the lock
yeah my wife's like the door to her
office was like when it rained it
expanded and I'm like I'll just put this
in here and I literally broke it off we
had to call locksmith and get it I felt
like I was the mayor of dumb people uh I
have a Tesla now and I have lost the key
and but the car seems to still be
working yeah I could have my phone okay
so as long as I have my phone but I love
it why did they give us tickets because
people could drive your car with the
without having access to your car via
their phone if they just have the key
Dan I want you to explain to him how the
frunk works anyway uh Paul Soder is with
us if you know or you recognize this
voice you recognize if you're watching
this on YouTube of course you're
probably a fan of Super Troopers and
broken everything great that the Broken
Lizard group has done and personally
Paul and I were pages together other at
CBS back in 1994. so we have a deep deep
long history and I just remember being
in that group of people some really
talented people in that group and
thinking all right some of us are going
to do some really amazing stuff it that
made it the coolest job and I had gone
out of college and you know Broken
Lizard was trying to get stuff going but
I needed a job and I had had terrible
jobs I worked at behind the pen counter
of a stationary store I'd worked at
Guggenheim as a as a guard like the
worst Museum guard in the world
hilarious and then when I landed on that
it was it's just so awesome because it
Not only was then a way to pay the bills
but it did feel like an incubator like
they were creative people 25 Pages all
within a few years being out of college
all wanting to get an entertainment or
TV or news or whatever uh and going out
together every night and you know and
riffing constantly and bullshitting
constantly and I you know I loved it and
I'm like so every single ounce of
success when I see something like this
you have a new movie out we're going to
talk about it at the top of the second
break quasi we're going to talk about
all of it but I just am so proud of you
and I'm psyched for you buddy thank you
thank you it's I'm amazed that all these
years later
they'll let you make it that's just the
way it rolls I think yeah and at this
point if it's cheap enough yeah if it's
cheap if it's cheap
I also had a our uncle had a sign in his
print shop he said you can get it good
cheap or fast
if it's good and cheap it's not gonna be
fast if it's good and fast it's not
gonna be cheap if it's fast and cheap
it's not gonna be good yeah pick two
pick two uh the other thing is one thing
that's sort of like a constant running
through all your movies and you guys
play this the true place is so well dumb
is such a running theme the dumbness of
your characters the idiocy of the cops
and Super Troopers
the idiocy is like the uh the charge and
it really off of there explodes
everywhere into the stories yeah and and
I think
um but the key is then uh it should be
written smart yes to sound like oh no
convincingly dumb like that's always the
thing is people like oh your movies are
so dumb I love it they're dumb and
you're like well yes the guys are guys
are celebrating how you guys are done
we're perceptively dropping in these
things and that's what I feel like this
show why I think you're uniquely
engineered and designed for this show
because we get dumb stories sent To Us
by our fans and then we try and figure
out what happened we don't say that's
dumb we say what happens
10 decisions that led to it so Jay hop
into a story right now this is sent in
by Kyle Spike Spicer okay at TV Kyle
biker uh this okay I I'm just gonna read
the headline let's hear it and this is
one of those headlines quote just the
way I felt a woman who called 9-1-1 over
pink barbecue tells her side of the
story wait call 911 over pink barbecue
tell is that a bad thing pink barbecue
the barbecue meat was pink she called
9-1-1 she only had one option Paul she
had to call 911 now look if you oh my
God I want kids called 911 every time
there's pink inside my roast pork loin
that's right this would be this I'm this
new rule
unless you are a child or you have
mental health issues if you are calling
9-1-1 just because you're pissed yeah
because you have to go to jail for a
week right you don't agree that should
be now you do get a strike maybe two
strikes but but on the third one hey
that's just the deal but again when you
call this you'd say are you sure you
want to do this they probably do do you
think she said we give them all for the
chances are on the vote are you shut the
Flop rule in sports I don't like now
they're penalizing players whoa Siri
just told me that's not nice they're
penalizing people for flopping right
this isn't a basketball you can't do
this Paul you can't just call 9-1-1 when
you're pissed maybe not prison but at
least a week I like community service
right but that 9-1-1 operator was
probably like checked off a board like
yet another call or pink Barbie Barbie
oh my God if I had a nickel for everyone
who complained about pink Barbecue on
the tied up this line with a pink
barbecue complaint yeah uh WRAL news on
Friday spoke to the woman who ripped
into a local barbecue restaurant for
serving your pink meat and cook so her
name is cook so maybe if your name is
cooked it feels like she knows more than
most can cook she thinks and Ken Cook
said she has had barbecued other
restaurants and it was never pink so
you're an expert right you're a food
critic is what you're saying right no
you've just had barbecue you're gonna
freak out with the name of this place
okay yeah go go I was just going to say
I it reminds me it's been a while if you
guys have Asian ribs Asian barbecue pork
ribs some of those are pink very pink
wonderfully delicious yeah that's that's
how they're supposed to be so there's a
tinge of racism
I don't like the way that okay at least
lack of knowledge lack of knowledge
ignorance all right she's not an expert
the issue started she said when she
returned to Clyde Cooper's Barbecue
Raleigh North Carolina I've been there
too North Carolina
barbecue and I think I was taken to kind
of an icon is like an iconic amazing it
came with us when we shot our
they don't ever screw up there like
everything is done with purpose there my
mouth is watering thinking about this so
here it is the issue started she said
when she returned to Clyde Cooper's
Barbecue to either have the restaurant
cook the barbecue longer serve her
something else off the menu or give her
a refund cook said none of these things
happened after she after she talked to
the owner of the restaurant we know the
owner of the restaurant owner of the
restaurants are really nice very nice
new her barbecue
cook said she wrote the negative review
because she felt the owner was being
dismissive of her concerns explaining
that that's just the way I felt that's
the reason why I called the cops because
I couldn't get my money back or I
couldn't get a different plan I'm with
you she's got to go to jail for a week
but that that I think the key part is
that's just the way I felt right you
live in an age now where it is that's
honor honor the feelings it doesn't
matter if the barber who's even pink or
not whether it was edible or not right
just the way I felt I felt not heard I
felt disrespected did not feel heard so
you have one option and my feelings were
as important as someone who may be in a
car accident or a house fire oh no I
need to be domestic I'm going to be
heard by someone my feelings
I deserve these resources my feelings
are more than the truth Dan and can't
cook
uh okay we can't judge can we cook I
don't think her I don't have a problem
with them saying we are not gonna reheat
this right or cook it longer I I don't
have a problem with the business owner
going that's what we gave you that's how
we serve things I think in that case
maybe give somebody a refund like I
don't think their requests are crazy to
say could you either give me something
else or cook this longer or give me a
refund I don't think that's crazy I also
think you know Illinois especially
Wisconsin you go to a lot of like bars
and restaurants where they're just like
we're not serving Canadian Club whiskey
today and you can see it's on there
they're just not doing that that day so
they said we'll do what if what if the
the restaurant said she said we'll do
this but you can never ask for this ever
again this is the one time we'll do this
fine how about they say we'll give you a
free meal all you can eat we'll cook
this until it's dark dark brown great
you have to stand up in front of
everyone and say I'm an idiot right you
have to say that or offer her that he
gives her I'll give you a free lemonade
and she says this lemonade is Pink
I think lemonade Debbie Holt the owner
of Clyde Cooper
she said uh she did offer the cuff
customer a different meal but cook
refused okay so see see she's like I'll
give you something requests every
restaurant in the world is like fine
I'll just just customers
nobody says
this is an interesting development
because the requests were fine with me
and obviously it's uh Debbie agreed
right we're not going to do any of those
three things but we'll offer you so what
what when that happens one of them cook
was given a piece of chicken in a brown
paper bag and not the full chicken plate
she expected okay so now she's expecting
something else that she didn't get cook
told well she got sides with her meat so
she already has those sides she doesn't
need a whole nother plate she wanted me
with the mashed potatoes two pink guys
is that what happened that's right Dan
you're so right the other things weren't
pink she already got the other thing the
sides are fine cook till wal news on
Friday that she is considering filing a
civil
honestly I hope you lose everything you
own do you guys find that you guessed
you start getting a little hot when
you're yes
that's why I don't go to Yelp anymore
because every review is some version of
this story no it actually is rating the
quality of food it is it is about how
everybody like felt somehow disrespected
but one of your comedy Partners the app
vouch fault that's a place where you can
go where it's just gonna be possible
yeah yeah it's like it's like the
antidote to Yelp because vouch for all
those people what do you love oh and
trust and what do you love right and why
do you love it like again the things we
love in this world like we have
restaurants anytime anybody goes to
Chicago I'm like you got to go to Dove's
luncheonette you have I'm going to
Chicago twice in the next month you've
got to go to Dublin you have to go to
ever it's my buddy's restaurant aren't
they the same ever and Dove luncheon are
the same owners I believe yeah
ever in Dove's luncheonette I'm just
gonna say it's a side by and it's it's
it's we just got back from Austin a
great food phenomenal and it is I love
nothing more we had a recommendation
from my brother-in-law I knew these guys
who opened a restaurant there's nothing
better than going to a restaurant and
they hook you up and it's it's
somebody oh yeah yeah we had the
freaking best the best place in Austin
it's called Ember and it's new and it's
a Latin flavored Steakhouse
is it downtown or near downtown yeah
yeah it was uh off of we're going to be
there this weekend when this drops when
this drops we'll be there that very
that'll be cool I'm going Amber I will I
will call because of them let them know
we're coming wagyu strip steak
this turned out to be a very why didn't
I
this is justice that you'll like Clyde
Coopers is seeing an influx of customers
since the incident yes the rest your
idiot a restaurant posted on Facebook on
Friday thanking people for the pink
barbecue love after Cook's criticism
that's right Holt said cook didn't
understand that it's normal for the
restaurant to cook pork barbecue that
way you said it you said it she took a
screenshot of the review which has since
been deleted and posted on social media
I'm gonna use your [__] against you and
it's going to make me money that's why I
love Debbie Holt she's like she's an
innovator and she took the thing that
she jiu jitsued the review sure yeah is
it unless you know in the today's day of
everything as a conspiracy some might
say but was Debbie in it yeah
that's my favorite Drake song by the way
home plan
cook eventually called 9-1-1 okay I have
a 14 year old son uh cook invention
called 9-1-1 after leaving the
restaurant hold said before the 911 call
Holt tried to explain several times to
the disgruntled customer why the meat
was pink right even other customers
tried to chime in you know that was a
good moment all from the over at the
counter
some guy over here waiting for 20
minutes to pick up their spare ribs like
me and Paul just did it I'm gonna say
something I'm gonna say some of this
lady I'm gonna say it for one I'm gonna
submit it should I say something I'm
gonna say something it's supposed to be
pink Anna good no she didn't hear you
you got to go over here all right she
said uh even other customers try to
chime in I kind of snickered a little
bit and told her honey the honey was
like my pejorative honey is like Listen
sweetheart honey that's when the
barbecue is smoked it turns pink and she
was insistent it wasn't done Holt said
she offered to bring another meal white
meat chicken because obviously this is a
white racist she said cook did not make
a fuss then left and died 9-1-1 okay so
she did not make a fuss when she
received her chicken Daniel she walked
out the door she didn't about face in
her kids in these instances and Paul
tell me if you feel this way
if so if the place makes a gesture of
acknowledgment that like we'll give you
even if it's not domestic attempt that's
right to me it's like if this if the
restaurant's like no we're not going to
do this isn't what we can walk away and
say I'm going to tell everyone I know
don't go to this restaurant like they
made the gesture to give her another
meal you have to accept that as them
saying look we understand even if we
disagree with you maybe it's not to
you're like maybe start your liking
we're going to do this for you because
we're nice and she couldn't handle it
imagine the dispatcher Imagine This
Woman's husband who has is like he
probably is like through this whole
thing see do you see what I have to deal
with him she's not legally separated
maybe she's a husband yeah
right
so yeah there's a very like smug
ex-husband right now I've been telling
you have I not been telling you he's
been telling her even telling us he's
been telling us for years and I just
needed the rest of the public to
understand he said it he said it last
year he said she won't do this uh I had
ordered some food from there and the
barbecue is pink the woman told 9-1-1 I
asked for either for them to cook it
some more exchange my order if you're a
911 you hang up right there you hang up
interrupt this well first you say is
this person having a stroke on the air
all right on the call is this person
having a psychotic break
yeah to cook it somewhere exchange my
order they said they're saying the meat
is supposed to be pink I asked them to
change my order and they said they're
not giving my money back and they're not
going to trade out the food Holt said
that after uh she called 911 police a
ride so why would the police come Dan so
now we're going to they have to come if
you call 9-1-1 okay yes no but that's
good you know we're riding Super
Troopers three and so that's please read
this please write a pink barbecue
work for Law and Order and have us be
the guys who are complaining about twin
brothers complaining the meat is is it's
changing and someone has to explain to
us and then it turns into an eating
contest between us and the cops if we
can out eat them then we win right there
you go pitch when the cops came through
he had a cute little smile on his face
and rolled his eyes and his arms were
folded I bet he came down because he
wanted to see is that in there yeah Holt
said I don't even think he said much to
me except I got you I got yeah the cop
is like you wanted to come down
into her back okay so the beef the beef
didn't stop there cook left a one star
review on Google and a photo of the
barbecue plate she also complained the
cheese in her mac and cheese was not
melted it was five hours ago before you
started when you tested that that mac
and cheese is very good it's so good we
ate it yeah it's a good this is a Side
Drive I took my five hour old mac and
cheese we uh I said we just got back
from Austin and now that we're when
you're promoting something for the
studio you fly first class I never fly
first ever yeah but the plane was
delayed five and a half hours and so
then when we finally went wheels up the
first class stewardess came by and said
to everybody
you would normally have a meal but the
meal has now been sitting here for five
and a half hours and you're like I'll
eat it this I don't feel comfortable
serving it I was like well how about if
I have a look I don't feel comfortable
and and I just couldn't I couldn't get
her to bring it to me she wouldn't bring
it to me because I was of course would
have eaten you would have eaten it five
hours this is not a first time stomach
this is
not a first time I have a I have a coach
stomach that's sitting up here and I'll
eat five hours the amount of room
temperature food I've eaten in my life
Dan five hour meatballs
freaking cooked are you ready for my I
would have looked at me like I wish you
wouldn't have told me yeah who would
have Dan my kids ate my daughter ate mac
and cheese and then put it in the sink
but nothing had touched it and about
probably an hour and a half later I went
by the sink sure with her spoon yes it
had been sitting in the sink in a bowl
doesn't it in a bowl yeah yeah but it
was just in the it had been discarded
you're not going on with you no stop I
gave my daughter less leftovers for
lunch that next day and then the lunch
that sat in her room for an entire day
not a refrigerator and then I was taking
out and I'm like I can't throw this away
and I ate it a daylight that's where I
am yeah so five hour five hours
I'll eat it same thing kids come home
from school they have not been sitting
in the sun in the Sun
and even like a like a I kind of like an
old PB J that's had about five I think
it's softer it's soft are you saying to
decant I want my I want my jelly
decanted I want it out so what we're
saying to you is you made a mistake by
not calling 911 is there a statute of
limitations
not for Anne cook there isn't this is it
she also complained the cheese in her
mac and cheese was not melted But Clyde
Coopers explained that this is a special
smoke cheddar that adds flavor Holt says
so she has no hard feelings though tell
her to come back and I'll educate her
about North Carolina style barbecue I
love her I'd be happy too I'll educate
her is like the most talking down to
someone and then the article said this
as if to give one last stick of the
before in the back of this woman the
last health inspection for Clyde
Cooper's Barbecue showed the restaurant
had a 96.5 which is in a Grade there you
go take that I probably should have made
you guess what the agreed number was
I got news for you that's just the way
it goes that's the way the the way the
pork that's the way the pork gets pinked
but if you talk about your travel show
that I I would watch a show where you
guys an episode would be you take and
back for that you know that that okay
we're gonna settle this we're going to
explain this to you so we I love it yeah
for another friend of ours was trying to
pitch a show with us hosting like Yelp
Justice where you really and I say you
find the people who gave a horrible
review and then you bring them back and
then you try and educate and in a funny
way and I wanted to call the show Yelp
wanted all right we put it out there in
the world nobody take that idea from us
Paul Soder is here he's got a new movie
called quasi I can't wait it comes out
in two days from when this drops we're
gonna talk all about it after the break
it's not people Town don't go anywhere
townies we got a sponsor we want to talk
to you about it is Maeve and ran is in
love with it I love Maeve so much
because your dog loves it so much so
Ponyo little Ponyo loves Maeve so much I
started feeding it for her it's a it com
it's amazing food that is just it's raw
it's raw food and by the way the fact
that it's frozen is a good thing that I
spoke to the may people about because it
helps clean little ponyo's teeth hey she
loves crunching on those things and it's
fantastic and I feel like I'm spoiling
my dog here I'm giving my dog great food
to eat and you're taking care of her
that's the other care of her I feel good
about it I also I have a dog that have
to watch her wait I have to be careful I
don't want her to get too fat I don't
want her to eat things that are low in
protein and high in carbohydrates the
Maeve diet is so much better for the dog
and I feel like okay I'm doing a good
thing for her and I'm Gonna Keep the vet
bills down so Maeve supports benefits
you can smell feel and see for better
breath reduced itching shedding all
those regular bowel movements we need
and maintaining a healthy weight like he
just said most dog parents see results
in 28 days or less plus there's no mess
no prep no thoring no thawing at all
just open pour and serve it is that easy
so right now guys you can make the
switch to Raw today right now Maeve is
offering 40 off your first order at
meatmave.com DPT so you're going to want
to go to meetmave.com
DPT and it's spelled
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars
off your first order that's meet Maeve
m-a-e-v.com slash DPT best dog food I've
ever ever given my dog townies this show
is sponsored by betterhelp and we are
therapy people we all have benefited so
much from therapy this is not just you
going through a crisis this is a way to
deepen your self-awareness this is a way
to understand who you are a lot of times
we can say these things to our friends
but they are not impartial not the same
thing it's a weighted be stressify is
that a word uh some of your
relationships by actually speaking to a
professional talking about
self-discovery you're talking about
working through some hard things and so
we believe in it or just everyday stress
yes yeah I mean and certainly in our
world stress is piled up and it's all
over the place and better help is the
way if you're thinking about starting
therapy yeah give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule now here's what you're gonna do
Tony's you just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com DPT
today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp help help.com DPT hey
Tony's are you looking for the perfect
gift for Mom or another loved one well
we've got the answer for you you guys do
have the answer I love this thing so
much we got this gift for our mom a few
years back and it has been the greatest
gift ever I just celebrated we
celebrated Amy's birthday recently and
what do you do every time you're out you
take a great picture okay I send it to
Mom and I send it to the Skylight frame
I love Skylight frames it's a very
beautiful little picture frame it's not
that little actually it sits on Mom's
right next door two different sizes two
sizes sits right next to our mom's couch
she gets a little ding when she hears
that a new pictures and new pictures
whenever we do something and then it
just rotates the pictures in it hooks in
with her Wi-Fi it's so easy it's so easy
to set up our mom could deal with it and
our and she was able to like manage it
and go through it's very simple once you
set it at once it just rolls forever
wherever you are whenever you take a
good picture you send it to that person
it's a great way to stay connected your
mom loves it she lives in St Louis we're
in LA and she feels so connected best
Mother's Day gift we've ever gotten ever
gotten guys so be like the scars the
Skylight digital photo frame is a sweet
and meaningful gift that will give you a
new way to stay in touch with those you
love it's so simple and fun to use as
they said even if you're not tech savvy
as I just said no app or subscription
required to send photos at any time from
anywhere it's a great way to feel close
to those you love even when you're far
away
if you love your mom and I we know that
you do another loved one that you want
to send this to as well so what we're
going to say is right now a special as a
special Mother Day Mother's Day offer
get 10 off that's up to 30 off your
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
DPT to get 10 off up to 30 off your
purchase of a skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com DPT that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash d p
t
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into the second story before we
get into the movie and all that stuff
this is the 18th when this thing drops
of April uh this week we are going to be
at the moon tower Comedy Festival we're
going to be in Austin at one of the best
comedy festivals ever Atlanta is doing
the living wake of Big Jay oakerson a
whole bunch of stand-up sets a bunch of
stand-up sets we are doing tag it which
is our show where comedians do stand up
and when Randy and I sit on the side and
write extra tags for jokes and then we
come up in between and Pitch them the
joke we did it for your buddy Jay
shander steakhart he did it he had a
joke about he's like the worst cow in
the world would be a ghost cow on a farm
because it would walk around and say Boo
Boo and everyone would be like no it's
supposed to be moved
titters weird laughs he's like what do I
do with that joke and so I came up and I
said look I know that joke is a little
weird but and I really want to get rid
of it but I'm Indian and it's a joke
about a cow and I just can't kill it all
right so he loved that and I used that
to the joke so we write tags we tag your
comedy and then we came on stage and we
pitched them to you tag it and then we
are doing a live dumb people Town agree
with this podcast and we've got a green
leadership is our Dulce Sloan and uh
Natalie palmitas it's gonna be so much
fun so moon tower will see you there and
then in uh in May we're going to be uh
in Minneapolis at the Acme Comedy
Company which is so good uh and then we
have other dates in the fall but uh
Daniel yeah the next weekend uh the last
weekend of April I'll be in Denver and
then my show here in La at the cats
crawl every other Monday with Myself and
Irene two all right Paul let's talk
about quasi I'm so psyched for you I
mean Jay was telling us about this movie
months ago and it's finally here you're
getting a little theatrical release are
you doing what's the deal no straight to
Hulu straight to Hulu right honestly I'm
realizing now you know we've never done
that before yeah and it's a cool thing
because really I mean it's an event the
old way of of thinking is always
theatrical is you know premium and
streaming is is somehow less not anymore
you know 90 more and also that was
always you know fans came up to us and
most of them were consuming our stuff at
home after seeing it on cable on there
yeah on their couches with their buddies
communal environment there might be a
bong maybe there might be a bong to us
it feels like we're cutting out the
middleman which is kind of cool but then
also
um
we're out promoting now and it's always
the most fun part of the project because
like I said I was in Austin we did an
Anaheim Ducks game and it's always so
much fun but anytime in the past it's
building towards a theatrical release
and so there's still always a pit in
your stomach what if people don't go out
what if there's a problem what if the
weather sucks the box office number on
Monday and everyone's going to read
variety
and with streaming I mean obviously we
we want people to see it and of course
Hulu will be psyched if a lot of people
come see it but it's nice to be able to
go promote and not always still also be
really nervous so let's break it down in
one paragraph what are people going to
see when they see this movie it's the
broken lizard's tribute to Monty Python
and Mel Brooks so it's the first time
that we've done something historical
that's the first time we've done
something with like costumes and and
period pieces period peace comedy and
because that's what we were raised on
and
this was really written this is one of
the things that we wrote really not long
after we knew each other and we were
still doing sketch comedy and so the
stuff that we were writing was very much
like our sketch routines about costumes
and silliness and absurd accents
and when Super Troopers 2 came out the
studio said all right well what else do
you have well yeah you've got to always
say this is a lesson to anyone who's
getting this you always got to have
something else when they ask you what
else do you have yeah when something
comes out you have to have another thing
in the shoe and uh this was just one
that we had always gone back and
reworked and Revisited because we loved
it but we really didn't think it was
going to get made because it's so off
brand for us and amazingly searched I
was like that's hilarious let's let's do
it we want we need to start making some
movies for Hulu and you know we wouldn't
do this theatrically but yeah it's
perfect for for Hulu and we were like
you really want to make this all right
let's do it so it became this like dream
come true for us because it's we're
playing multiple characters everything
is over the top and again accents and
it's just the kind of thing we didn't
think we'd ever get to do and it has
been made since python like you think
about it and those movies did great
people have like us have memories of
those and we came even a little after
those movies came out but they still
affected us but well I haven't I don't I
can't think of a movie that's come out
like that since then they've done the
new history
which definitely uh isn't that same same
world
um so it's the Quasi so it's the story
of Quasimodo uh uh a hunchback story set
in 13th century France and he gets
caught up in this political Intrigue
between the king of France and the pope
each of them pulls him aside and
commands that he assassinate the other
and so he's like wait a minute if if I
don't murder the pope then the king will
send me to death between a king and a
pope he's yeah the classic Kingdom he
plays a rock in the hard place which is
The Rock in that situation it was hard
I'm the hard person my nickname I love
it so it comes out April 18th on Hulu
watch it uh you can watch it at one in
the morning yeah
we're dropping on the 18th 420 perfect
idea all right number 420. you know what
to do you know you know what to do
all right we're giving you all the
breadcrumbs guys we're leaving so we're
leaving you all the resins and then
here's the best part watch the first
night and then watch it the next three
nights again and again on Hulu because
then you catch all the jokes all those
jokes here in here because you were
laughing your buddies were laughing it
got so loud yeah I love it are you guys
ready should we jump in the store
congratulations trigger warning for
everyone right now stop eating if you're
listening to this another food one oh
yeah here we go because in this one you
could have called 9-1-1 I just just
because okay I'll be the judge of that
this was sent in by Carlene McDermott at
shebe Carlene one of our favorite people
who sends in stories you're a
contributor huge all right here we go
here's the headline Airline claims
cockroach and this was in parentheses so
I'm like was it in Congress yeah found
in in-flight meal was actually sauteed
Ginger you could have had that in first
class
so now they're fighting Ginger now
they're simply moving around yes we had
trouble killing it yes it had legs that
is sauteed Ginger my fear when you say
does it your sauteed somebody fall
asleep on a plane in a cockroach
that happens no it's on that I think now
in some cultures this would be
considered a delicacy sure Jay and I've
eaten bugs respectfully right crickets
what's the problem here grasshopper
Chapel anus what did they say
chabeliness chop choppelinas what do
they saute the cockroach in that's my
question you don't saute a cockroach and
ginger let me just say that right off
the bat that's cargo it loses all of its
natural juices what is your ignorant
yeah garlic butter thank you thank you
an airline has claimed that a passenger
thought uh what a passenger thought was
a cockroach and the in-flight meals was
actually a piece of sauteed Ginger so
this is full on the world we live in
right now that is a cockroach no it's
not it's Ginger I hate when this
happened this happened to me at a bar
here in L.A where I was like a month of
burger I don't want the onions on like
grilled onions on the burger they bring
it out just grilled onions and they're
like no there's not and I'm like
yesterday I'm looking at it you think I
brought grilled onions just in kind of
four and a half yeah like there's honey
sounds like no no you're all good you're
not you're good you're good we're not
all good good nice and I just was like
this is a cockroach yeah you're good
yeah you're good okay I was so caught
off card yeah you're like what a stance
it's gaslighting that is the that is the
definition of gas cockroach lighting all
right traveler Nicole solanki took a
picture of the debated find on his
flight from Mumbai to Bangkok on the
31st of August share it on social media
in the middle of October that's why you
don't order a meal on Spirit Air
tweeting a photo of an in-flight meal
and a zoomed in shot of what looks like
some kind of bug in a rice dish he
posted it with the caption small
cockroach in air vistara meal so he's
calling them out yeah he's calling him
out but the carrier disagree with his
assessment saying the meal had been
analyzed in a lab
they analyzed in a lab was it I mean was
the lab in Wuhan um who knows classic
Airline red tape move by the way too
it's been analyzed in life so you're not
saying it isn't you're saying it's been
analyzed what they're saying we after
you complained and we told you it was
Ginger on the flight right we also then
went ahead and sent it to a lab just
yeah you know it could have been make
sure that the ginger is sent the picture
to a lab and they did an enhancement
photo lab a photo yeah right so Mr
solanki you know all those planes where
everything has to be put away or thrown
away or closed latched yeah locked it's
like a boat right like a boat they were
like leave that food out because it's
definitely Ginger but we want that to be
analyzed
so we know that it is [__] the black box
and by the way more important things way
more listen down you're gonna hold that
plate the whole Landing yeah this is how
they come in hot the airlines response
quote we'd like to clear the air I mean
we don't need that pun we don't need
that pun regarding tagline
hey what's the name of the airlines we'd
like to clear the air uh regarding the
meal that was served to on your flight
with us dated 31st of August from Mumbai
to Bangkok you know they were asking
like all those kinds of questions that
they like they know they're screwed like
all the questions they're asking the
sample was sent to a laboratory and
thoroughly tested based on the reports
we can confirm that no foreign object
slash insect was found in the particular
meal sample so sounds like you can't
confirm it's Ginger why right also like
if you just have the results like who's
going to argue oh what do the results
taste this tell me if that's Ginger
right the option question evaluated in
the mic under a microscope and was found
to be a piece of saute Ginger is that
their version of being like we used real
science we put it under a microscope
well Labs you send it to Burger Lab oh
that's right
that's right the Burger Lab that doesn't
feel scientific enough the message
finished we here at vistara leave no
stone unturned in ensuring that the
highest standards of safety and services
are upheld they're gonna [__] they're
gonna lie to you is what they're gonna
do uh an unconvinced MR solanki demanded
proof commenting Airlines right without
evidence uh please attach original lab
report Ginger or cockroach so he's never
to the point though you are going you're
the hero who eventually is going to
become a Villain Like Let It Go yeah
like you've also you're like like your
kids are like Dad Dad stop come to bed
honey come to bed I can't that's the
thing
it always is the principle but sometimes
you gotta let the principal that's right
you gotta accept your loss and move on
all right do you have the picture uh I
don't know if I have it in here but I
will find it must look like a bug a
vistara spokesperson told the
independent we came across a tweet by a
passenger complaining about a meal
served him so there by the way is
probably a division of people at vistara
who are like look we know there's going
to be some [__] bugs in the thing
right let's just make sure that no one's
tweeting about it and if it is they're
like we got to get on this guy we'll
send it to the lab which is over at
Jerry's house and then the social media
intern has one job for tweets about bugs
about bugs in Google you search these
two key words
the meal samples in the laboratory
thoroughly checked under digital stereo
microscope is that a thing that's a
microscope digital stereo microscope to
me sounds like that's not it probably is
a thing and we're dumb but it sounds
like what a six year is that a cockroach
that's the photo in question that looks
like a cockroach right I don't know yeah
it is very we already shared these
findings with the customer via email on
uh September 14th we had Vistar La
utmost importance in maintaining
stringent standards of safety so all our
processes are aligned towards the same
it's not the first time a passenger has
complained about finding something
unsavory in their Innings they said that
about themselves
I appreciate your audience
everybody else was [__] yeah I'm
gonna admit that I don't know what this
is Jay I'm going to admit that right it
could be Ginger it could be shrimp I'm
gonna say why does everyone who needs to
take an important photo whether it's I
know this isn't it looks like shrimp
Bigfoot or this it's old and I think
they took it from further away and this
is a zoomed in shot okay in 2019 this is
not going to help their case out all
right Paul in 2019 a passenger on a
Mumbai bound flight from uh Bhopal
discovered a large cockroach and
cockroach in his breakfast on board an
Air India flight I informed Air India
crew but they ignored me let me can I
ask but he in his in the airlines events
he did order a bowl of rochios
they're part of it they're like raised
anything he didn't get enough they're
the little and he's like I only have
three I should have eight in this bowl
uh I'm trying to the the testimony of
they ignored me just to be unbelievable
like that what they just kept walking
pastors
they would come over they would undo the
button they're like
them undoing the button and then keep
walking that's a power move
because all they have to do is look at
you and go what would you like me to say
you did since the crew since the crew
members were not listening I returned it
to them I even objected to their serving
food to others but to no avail so now
this person is trying to protect the
plane right the airline subsequently
issued an apology saying in a statement
we sincerely apologize for the incident
where our valued passenger had a
disappointing experience with the meal
served aboard our Bhopal Mumbai fight
flight Air India always Endeavors to
ensure our passengers enjoy our services
we've taken seriously serious note of
the incident and immediately issued a
strong notice to the caterer concerned
which by the way doesn't even seem like
you should be like we're switching
Caterers right even if you aren't sure
or or how about here's a 500 this is my
question you're on a flight with a meal
and there's a cockroach in your food
what is the easiest way for it to be
made right for you but give me give me a
free flight free flight it has to be
domestic International domestic 500
value you're saying if they were like oh
my God we are so sorry here's a free
flow we don't know what this is what if
they were like let me get you another
meal you would still feel like no I
would not eat you would not want to eat
I would need another thing on that
flight from them what if they're like if
you were a loyalty person and they're
like we're gonna give you 20 000 miles
no I mean so this was this was exactly
what happened I I hate to keep going
back to my Delta flight last night it's
all still fresh yeah yeah no you said
that's what that's what this show is for
ultimately uh she went around and told
everybody
um because you can't have a cockroach
you have a meal uh um well I don't want
to serve you the meal that's been
sitting for five hours and you always
like I'll take it you'll get I think it
was a voucher it was
like 20
2500 no no what's it good 20 you know
2500 uh Sky miles yeah but I didn't have
it I don't have a Delta Sky miles
account and I'm like okay do I say that
like yes
and you say everyone on this plane I
have an announcement I do not have a
Delta Sky miles account let's figure out
how she can compensate yeah
I'm still willing to eat the tilapia
how do we make this how can I get this
woman to serve me the room temperature
now smoking yeah so there you go I think
you can just give you a voucher no just
like I'd be like can I just get a 50
voucher anyway so cockroach or Ginger it
could be a new a new thing it's like
who's the [__] cockroach or Ginger it
could be a new category block or charge
Locker charge I was a kid my we opened a
bag of frozen vegetables because when we
were kids nobody ate fresh vegetables in
a can everything and there was a spark
plug in our bag probably like bird's eye
mixed vegetables and now I think about
boy this was happened now like we're in
the money we're gonna you know we're
gonna I can't wait to see them you just
threw it away and maybe use it in here
you put it in your car see if that works
like and let it roll all right there you
go that's Story number two Daniel give
us a little taste of what we're gonna
hear in segment number three big company
dumb move big company dumb move Paul
Soder is our guest the movie quasi comes
out 420 bro 420 bro you can watch it on
Hulu it's gonna be great we'll be right
back with more dumb people town right
after this
[Music]
boredom
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
Daniel take us home all right all right
here we go yes sent in by brewpounder at
brewpounder nice
it looks one's definitely coffee maybe
he's a beer fest fan oh yeah maybe it's
a cold brew beer fest fan maybe I don't
know okay here we go North Carolina
we're back we're back we're back it all
comes Full Circle North Carolina
Chick-Fil-A faces backlash over asking
volunteers to work drive through for
food not pay ooh huh yeah that's the
barter the fact that no I always think
about this when things go through so
many levels that then it becomes never
like wait it was straight you want
people to volunteer to come work at a
very successful there's two kitchen to
give food to like homelessness
Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A where a place
where they're gonna profit off of you I
love it this is like all of food this is
our Paul soda food episode
very delicious our dumb food with Paul
Soder a Chick-fil-A restaurant in
Hendersonville Henderson North Carolina
is facing online criticism after issuing
a call out on social media for
volunteers to work the restaurant's new
drive-through Express hey are you bored
today and want lunch come on down to
this corporations location and these
people can handle it I mean untrained
yeah is drive through where you want to
put untrained feels like a lot of
pressure feels like a lot of pressure by
the way I would look at the register
behind any of these things and be like I
can't do this no that would freak me out
I could clean clean if you gave me some
task where you you just put this in here
and you can make fries
the fries come from a pack if you don't
have to like put them through a potato
maker and they come from a package you
pour them in the basket you drop them in
the grease you press the button it'll
tell you when it's done you pull them
out shake them on the table shake a
little uh salt on them and you're good
getting hungry again but also I feel
like now don't their registers like they
really sort of idiot-proofed register
yeah
this is pictures yeah like I went to
Taco Bell recently don't tell my wife
goes
um how many times did you get more than
six Mexican
but I I also was trying to break it
break at 20. and uh so my uh what I
ordered was uh ten dollars and 81 cents
so I I gave him a 20 and 81 cents so
that I could get back the 10 the 10 that
I wanted yeah and it fried this guy
could not figure it out by the way just
like why did you give me the bill and
this because I just want to build back I
don't want 19 cents yeah meanwhile you
tell the story that you went to Taco
Bell to the woman in the first class
cabin and she's like bring the food out
yeah tilapia I'll bring it out
he just ate a Mexican pizza you guys
bring it up bring out the okay poke the
fast food chicken restaurant promised
free entrees instead of monetary
compensation we are look this is a quote
from their post we are looking for
volunteers for our new drive-through
Express the Hendersonville Chick-fil-A
said on Facebook uh it has since been
deleted after a flood of negative
comments yeah yeah it's a post from
earlier this week said volunteers would
earn five free entrees per shift one
hour worked and ask those interested to
message for details now there probably
is some one hour of working the thing
what are you doing this summer are you
um interning for Google no for
Chick-fil-A it's an internship do they
give you credits
no college credits
for chicken fingers the Hendersonville
Chick-fil-A has declined comma and
directed all media inquiries to the
corporate Press Room which is funny
because I guarantee this was a
franchisee let's do this and now they're
like hey can you guys handle this team
corporate's got to come down and talk to
this guy right well David Chick-fil-A
responded via email and linked to a
statement given by given to Business
Insider the corporate press team did not
answer questions submitted by the Times
News like it's Chick-fil-A and they're
like did you hire any gay people no all
right we're fine yeah we're good we can
fix this situation yeah Chick-fil-A
spokesperson told Insider on Wednesday
that the company did not endorse the
volunteer program and that the
restaurant had decided to end it so Dan
I feel like this is a story that started
late at night at Chick-fil-A as it's
closing down and the honors like hey you
know what we should do like it
definitely started in a hey you know
what we should do people love this
location you know those commercials
where the two people are sitting on a
couch and talking about how much the
Chick-fil-A saved their life like the
guy who worked at Chick-fil-A learned
sign language to communicate people love
us gut-wrenching stories right I cried I
literally cried it's like I think we've
earned enough Capital to hire violence
it's like it's like a chicken nugget
version of When Harry Met Sally yeah
like I love those stories probably like
this could go bad and then David was
like but if it works but if it were a
genius Free Labor yeah and we can
you want to put a three-year-old on
fries do it have you ever listened to
somebody tell you they're like giant
business plans and this
there's like nine things that have to
happen perfectly that will never happen
like when this happens then this is
gonna happen my rule is you're allowed
one if
even for myself like with somebody that
says like what's going on with whatever
project if I have more than one if I'm
not gonna happen all we gotta do all the
ideas
and granted that's a big if that's how
you know all of it stupid that's the
whole thing it's built on if people see
that we're just gonna offer them free
food they're gonna we're gonna have to
like step up and then if people really
get no no this is going to catch on
people realize oh I'm gonna do that for
a free meal then we're gonna get so much
free there's so much food that we say
falls on the floor we can give them that
kind of it went so successfully they
went bankrupt because they had given all
their customers there's no cars in the
Drive-Thru because everybody everyone's
working there yes I have this little
sketch in my head now at Chick-fil-A
corporate where they're they've gotten
this story and they're like okay
somebody's gonna have to go down and
talk to David and sort the [__] out and
they look over and they end up sending
the corporate intern who's working for
food he comes down is like this is what
this is my job
a fan of David that's right you guys
gotta get down here he's got ideas he's
got ideas I'm not coming back to
corporate this is a quote from you know
what he said he wants to make the
drive-through only motorcycle from their
spokesperson most restaurants are
individually owned and operated and it
was a program at an individually owned
restaurant right the Chick-fil-A
Facebook page has been interesting to
hear them distancing themselves away
from the matter David this is what I
love this works out naked Tuesdays is
going to happen if right Adam and Eve
days Chick-fil-A Facebook page day one
uh has been attracting comments on the
matter even after limiting who can
comment on the pages post they tried to
like
a post featuring a back of house
employee holding a young child eating an
ice cream cone receives comments such as
found a volunteer that works for ice
cream instead of sandwiches it's even
cheaper be aware there are child labor
laws in this country another said man
those volunteers sure are young yep cool
meme a thread on Reddit of course
everything goes you knew Reddit was
gonna get involve Paul which they say is
a popular social news Forum we know
containing a screenshot of the post
gained wide attention received nearly
how many interactions how many how many
do you think how many interactions I'll
go first I think 3 000 interactions okay
oh
you got this I believe everything yeah
we say 4 000 upvotes and one thousand
down votes five thousand interactions
okay yeah I'm gonna say 22 000
interactions it had
23 000.
and about 3 500 comments by Thursday
afternoon sure a top commenter asked
there's so much wrong here I don't know
where to start but first of all why not
just give money instead of vouchers does
he not understand how payroll works you
don't have to fill anything out for
vouchers
there's no exactly aren't they more than
minimum wage yes but you don't pay taxes
on vouchers you don't there's no
liability on a voucher that's right
while the restaurant is now seeking well
is now seeking volunteer labor
Henderson's Chick-fil-A gained attention
last summer after proudly announcing pay
raises for its employees this is
probably why they don't want to hire
anymore
this is actually really good the
franchise said full-time workers would
start at 19 an hour amazing in August
2021 that was a jump from the previous
April when Chick-fil-A Hendersonville
promised to staff 15 an hour dude that's
not a huge jump not all employees were
eligible for the 19 rate workers uh who
were 14 and 15 started at 12 per hour
and part-time employees at 14. I don't
know why this also wasn't eligible for
that the volunteers working on fries
yeah the guy the guy on the law worker
yeah yeah we've been fishing them out
with his hands the nine-year-old kid
working out you know we've done in and
out where it's so backed up that there's
a person out there taking care director
and it's a big deal with Portillo's in
the in the midwest you've got to have
the right type of person was there a
story at Waffle House where someone went
in the back and started making waffles
yeah probably last night I'm sure that
happens everywhere that's a good it's a
great story that story three yeah a show
Friends that is a show again the movie
is quasi I'm so two days from now 420
you're gonna go to Hulu you're gonna
watch this movie you're gonna give it
any positive reviews you can support it
share it with your friends tell people
to watch it too I'm so this is how great
movies like this will continue to get
made yeah absolutely great to have you
on this great job thanks buddy wait are
we done I've done that okay will you
want to say one more thing well go for
it they had told me to prepare a dumb
story oh I had a dumb story but then all
these stories are free these are all
dumb you'll come back and tell another
dumpster and you don't have to prepare
you don't have to prepare a different
story you're good you're good does it
have to do with the Delta flight I
wasn't born it is it fits in with
everything
we own this show so you guys know enough
about me now to know that I have this
emotional relationship with fast food
yeah I was a latchkey kid in McDonald's
my wife doesn't like it we get it do you
go many times and she doesn't know that
you go right you're probably gonna go
today
I'm in therapy and I go to 12 different
chickens they think you said three soft
tacos and you only said two but you just
leave it exactly
but I had a uh I had a work trip because
sometimes I'll do advertising work and I
had a I had a trip in Arkansas but I
also had a convention you have guys do
cons
in San Antonio and I had to be in uh
Arkansas tougher work so I decided I'll
just rent a car and go and give myself a
little road trip and that for me is
always the hardest thing is not just
giving in and every fast food place on
the way yeah and I had it was a long
drive yeah and there's always those
options that's it yeah yeah there's
nothing and I'm like but I'm I'm gonna
have willpower I'm gonna make it but it
was stressful and it started pouring and
and it turned into such a long trip and
I I finally and I was bleary-eyed and
hungry and tires in the middle of the
night and I stopped at a it's a you know
gas station with a McDonald's attached
and I had to stop for a gas no shame in
that and that just there was no way at
that point once I was in there I have to
qualify it any more than this but it was
just a really like just for me it was it
it felt you know thank you you said
Thank You Jesus
um what's up I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna do it I'm not gonna do it then you
gave in I'm getting gas I got the I got
I got the gas the nozzle in the rental
car and I look over
now the my only uh real issue with
McDonald's is you can't really customize
so what I always end up doing is I get
my quarter pound with cheese and then I
gotta open it up and I scrape the
pickles off I don't like the pickles
that's right so they will do that for
you no but no
it takes 40 minutes longer you don't
want to do it every time he's got to go
he's on a road trip and I hate pickles
so much that I won't touch them so I
also go through the fries and find the
kind of really hard Brown fry that I can
use as a tool you grab one of them
Crispies
so I am still I've gotten my uh
McDonald's and I'm standing by my car
and it's just finishing filling up and I
open up the
carton to to open up my my 100 pound of
cheese and get the pickles off and when
I look down there's a [__] cockroach
on my shoes no no no no no
scream I throw the McDonald's up in
these and the pickles go in your mouth
along with the Cockroach and I don't
know where the Cockroach goes but now
I'm like I'm terrified of course I run I
get in my car rental car and I drive off
with the nozzle the gas nozzle
[Music]
I knew that I hadn't really broken
anything and I drove and never looked
back but when I think about that as
being one of the dumbest things I've
ever done somebody reminded me of once I
got to Arkansas was like dude
you realize that that gas station has
cameras and that somewhere on a
surveillance video they're watching this
is their Christmas video on tape and I'm
like forever damn it if I'd really been
filmmaker Paul Soder loses his brain
you've made the new employee training
videos footage exists I guess they
probably wipe the tapes but just knowing
now that that moment was recorded and
and the camera will be so far away that
it won't see the Cockroach
nowhere freaks out like opened his
Quarter Pounder lost his brain drove off
with the thing that is a great story
there you go we got a little bonus story
bonus extra story that's how we do it
thank you Paul soda oh thank you guys so
much oh [__] we got to get back to work
gang
[Music]
Florida town